[Musik]
hey ihr lieben schön dass wir zu diesem
video gefunden habt ich habe euch meinem
letzten video gezeigt wie ich den grund
für meine motiv klick zu herstelle und
jetzt zeige ich euch was auf den theken
hübsches geworden ist wir fangen an mit
der vorbereitung der eheringe dafür wird
in etwas weißem von dante lose pulver
gemischt damit man besser damit arbeiten
kann und der fondant wir dann auf etwas
becker stärke ausgerollt den darf man
jetzt auch nicht zu dünn aus freuen uns
kann man damit nicht arbeiten ich habe
den circa drei millimeter dick
aufgerollt anschließend nehme ich mir
einen dicken strohhalm zur hilfe und
steche der kreise aus
um den inneren kreis auszustechen nehme
ich nur meine loch töne zu hilfe
die master haben perfekt aufeinander
gepasst ich schreibe euch auch noch mal
in die infobox vier zentimeter die
beiden jeweils im durchmesser hatten
je nachdem wie viele kekse ihr
zubereitet hat müsst ihr nun die
doppelte menge an ringen um die ringe
gold zu färben nehme ich am liebsten
puder farben ich verlinke euch das noch
mal ganz genau in die infobox
entweder mischt man die mit ethanol an
also mit alkohol
darauf wollte ich jetzt gerne
verpflichtende dinge habe ich das ganze
mittwoch vermisst das einzige was ihr
dabei beachten müsst wenn ihr das ganze
mit wasser vermischt das musst du viel
länger braucht sie trocknen ich habe das
etwa 24 stunden gemacht bevor ich die
dinger auf die kekse drauf geklebt habe
jetzt nehmt ihr euch einen sauberen
weichen pinsel und pinselt einmal die
goldfarbe über die ringe dabei immer
wieder drehen damit auch jede seite
bedeckt ist von der goldenen farbe und
dann lass dir das ganz normal trocknen
[Musik]
während dann meine ringe alle trocknen
können nehme ich mir schon mal meine
silikon not zu hilfe die habe ich von
wilden da haben wir besonders gut einmal
die blätter und die kleinen blumen
gefallen
dafür habe ich mir wieder etwas von den
rosa eingefärbt ich habe auch wieder cnc
reinen mit weil ich das ganze da einfach
viel besser verarbeiten kann
um die filigranen krönchen und förmchen
hinterher bis herauszubekommen wird das
ganze mit etwas becker stärke
ausgeklopft dann gehen wir auch schon
etwas von dann hinein und streiten den
überschuss mit unserer winkel palette ab
so kommt das türmchen auch wie von
alleine aus der form und beginnen mit
den blättern genau zu erfahren
und genau so machen wir dann weiter mit
den rappern dafür habe ich mein fondant
grün eingefärbt
[Musik]
da bleibt auch nichts daran haften die
blumen und die blätter die kommen wie
von selbst auf der form
als nächsten schritt rolle ich mir dann
auf etwas becker sterkel einen weißen
von land aus
hier verwende ich keins emc mehr das ist
in diesem fall nicht nötig anschließend
steche ich mir aus dem weissen fondant
mein herzchen auf mit denen ich auch die
kekse ausgesprochen habe dann nehme ich
mir meinen weg gebe da mit meinem pinsel
etwas zucker kleber drauf und darüber
kommt dann ein von land her schaut auf
jeden fall mal infobox das schreibe ich
euch sein wie ihr zucker kleber
innerhalb von ein paar sekunden selber
machen könnt danach kommen auch schon
die ringe zum einsatz da klebe ich auch
auf die grundfläche etwas zucker kleber
und kleben sie dann übereinander
auf die andere seite gebe ich dann noch
die blume und das blatt auf
[Musik]
jetzt werden auch noch die namen
eingestand in dem vom land dafür benutzt
sich immer bestimmte buchstaben
ausstecher wie verlinke ich auch in die
infobox
wichtig ist dass ihr darauf achtet der
von land muss auf jeden fall weicht ein
denn wenn er länger schnee zum beispiel
20 minuten dann wird das schon hart und
dann kann man da nicht mehr gut die
buchstaben einstand
[Musik]
an diesem besonderen tag habe ich
nützlich diese kekse machen dürfen und
hat deswegen immer parallel gearbeitet
denn wie gesagt eher von dann darf auf
keinen fall aus trocken bevor er die
namen darin einstand und da könnte die
super parallel arbeiten immer ein paar
kekse dekorieren die namen 1 standen und
dann immer so weitermachen
[Musik]
falls jetzt noch fragen habt bei der
herstellung wird das schönen tag wird
dann schreibt sie mir gerne in die
kommentare
ich beantworte die fragen so schnell wie
möglich außerdem lohnt es sich noch in
die info box zuschauen da schreibe ich
alles auf was wir benötigt und wie man
den zucker kleber selber macht
[Musik]
die fertigen kekse habe ich dann noch
ein tütchen verpackt und mit rosendekor
band verschlossen und am ende sei das
ergebnis wirklich sehr hübsch aus und
die gäste haben sich über die
gastgeschenke sehr gefreut
falls euch das video gefallen hat dann
freue ich mich sehr über einen daumen
hoch und über euer abo bis zum nächsten
mal auf wiki fitschen